and I'm gonna share it with you four
simple steps that you can get started
making money online today
what's up believe nation at seven I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's learn how
to earn $100,000 a year in robotic
income with Tai Lopez okay
how do I make money online people always
ask me how I make money and I thought
I'd just show you some actual
screenshots on my phone on different
products different businesses I have
here's today one of my companies here
seventeen thousand three hundred and
eighty four dollars today alone made
seven hundred and fifteen thousand in
the last month selling simple household
items you know I like books and that's
how much I said I sold in books and I
got another company you know I like
glasses so we sell glasses sleep glasses
I'll show you a little screenshot of
that one this is a Shopify this month it
sold 17,000 today it's done thirteen
hundred bucks there's an airplane coming
in we give you a tour and I'm gonna
share with you four simple steps that
you could get started making money
online today now you're not gonna start
out making seven hundred thousand
dollars a month like I'm doing it took
me a while to build up but telling you
it's easier to start now than it's ever
been because when I got started you
didn't have Shopify Amazon wasn't easy
to sell on you didn't have stripe to
collect credit card number you know to
collect the pretend process payment I'm
going to show you the four ways that get
started if you want within 24 hours
making money online now like I said it's
not a get-rich-quick scheme but trust me
there's simple household items around
your house
seven hundred thousand dollars in the
last month I've sold a books and book
related things you know educational
stuff more this is just one business you
could sell can know people selling
candles making a hundred grand I know
guys selling candles I think you're
gonna make a couple of million bucks
everywhere you look so step number one
to making money online find a household
item that's interesting to you that's
step number one find a simple household
item that's related to what you do on a
day-to-day basis like I said I sold 700
Donna sellin glasses 1300 today and
and this is just not showing Amazon
Amazon did about three or four thousand
a so about five thousand dollars a day
and I also do stuff related to sleeping
well cuz everybody's got a bed and gotta
sleep
step number two decide if you want to
sell using a website that you can build
on Shopify click funnels or you can just
use Amazon you need to decide between
those three step number three okay you
got to connect them and you got to get a
way to collect money so you can either
use stripe Braintree or if you sell on
Amazon they have built in you can
process through them I don't recommend
PayPal is your only source sometimes
depends step number four once you got
those is you need to white label the
products so you don't want to have to
create like if you want to sell glasses
or if you want to sell cosmetics or if
you want to sell tables you don't want
to actually manufacture them at least
not to start so there's a simple way
that you can use let's call white
labeling or drop shipping to take
products that people have and put your
own label and brand on it with that said
you can be up and going for those four
steps literally if you start early
enough today you can do it today
be up and running now like I said you
got to get sales but that comes if you
know how to do it Amazon literally has I
forget how many sales a day eighty
million sales a day different items sold
so if you do well on the Amazon echo
system people will find you especially
if you know how to rank their you know
for some of you you might be intimidated
by trying to make you know seven hundred
and fifteen thousand dollars a day by
the way we've been making money while we
were on this walk or on this walk made a
couple hundred bucks in the last couple
of minutes that's the beauty by the way
of selling online
I call it robotic income like robot
never gets tired it just does the work
if you build a website correctly using
Shopify or click funnels or Amazon they
never get tired those servers run long
as there's electricity they're running
and one of the cool things if you want
to make a hundred grand a year a lot of
people think it's hard to make a hundred
grand a year it is if you have a
nine-to-five job because you're only
working eight hours a day but a robot
never
is tired robotic income there's no end
it can run 24 hours a day did you know
to make $100,000 a year pull out a
calculator and do the math let me show
you $100,000 a year okay right there
divided by 365 days because a robot a
website can work non-stop is two hundred
and seventy three dollars a day right
100 divided by three out of six five
days then how many days are there how
many hours in a day you only got to make
eleven dollars and 41 cents an hour
eleven dollars forty one cents an hour
you making a hundred thousand dollars
here if you want to learn how to make a
thousand dollars a week garage sale
flipping with Gary Vee check out the
beter there right next to me I think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there if I was really doing this right
beside me I'd make a thousand a week
easy